so if Charles Whitman for example and it
could be possible
sixteen people because he had a brain
tumor that made him aggression yes okay
so he is he you were not holding him
responsible for what he did because he's
he's hidden oh yeah and I would say that
even he has to be kept yeah I don't know
lots of people are dangerous yeah no I
look I don't know that I don't agree
that I wouldn't hold him responsible I
don't know exactly what the effect of
the brain tumor is if the brain tumor
makes him think that he's not really
telling anyone then I wouldn't hold him
responsible yes but if the brain tumor
gives him a strong desire to kill people
then I hold him responding can't
overcome well what if you could remove a
brain tumor what what if you could
removed the brain tumor would you still
hold responsible afterward you mean then
he's a different person
I don't know that's a question is it's
all the quit piece right that's where
it's all right I think that we have a
better theory of Charles Whitman than a
freely operating thing right well you
know the theory that you'll go kill
people is better than one that he's
making rational decisions in my Senate
Armstrong has a detailed case of someone
who was a repeated sex offender yeah and
who was diagnosed as having a tumor that
was impressing a certain part of the
brain when it was removed he ceased
entirely to behave in these
inappropriate way towards his daughter
he was subsequently released from jail
the tumor regrew back and as it grew
back his behavior returned to its
previous lee indictable pattern and
again on the removal of the tumor his
behavior returned to normal so there's
no what does one make of this from the
perspective of
well I'm puzzled by the question that
Sean asked which you're also asking if
the tumor is out he's is he the same
person that he himself actually had a
first-person account of the entire train
of events which made it clear that from
the first person he thought of himself
as numerically identical over the
repeated interventions the criminality
the trials and ultimately did he say why
he did the foul deeds was that I had a
morever whelming desire these days and
of course he knew nothing about his his
brain tumor initially and the subsequent
overwhelming desires came upon him in
ways that did not reveal that they were
caused by the recurrence of the brain
tumor but which his physicians were able
to diagnose but you see that's key I
think when the question of the
responsibility of this man comes on him
the question is whether he had evidence
for the recurrence was there a time when
he should have known that he made her
along disabled and then we can say he's
responsible for not having taken the
steps if somebody commits a crime you
would need to discuss whether or not
there's none Saraya volition and I like
the volitional work better whether or
not there really is volitional freewill
we can't have society without having
that constructs we got to have that so
you've got to determine whether or not
there was criminal intent you could make
out you're making up cases that are very
much online I think it's pretty
irrelevant those are very unusually
special cases and the idea of convicting
somebody is for several purposes in my
view one is deterrence you want to keep
people from committing a crime of young
another is removing people from society
who in fact are or non rehabilitate able
I think the goal needs to be
rehabilitation if you guys really want
to punish people and take their
fingernails off because you're mad at
them I want to put that aside I
personally don't subscribe to that I
also think that this level of
while responsibility extends to
eleven-year-olds if eleven-year-old
commits a crime you also need to
determine these same things you need her
that behavior you make do it differently
you need to remove them from society
potentially and you try to rehabilitate
them so I didn't and by the way if it
turns out that they're not they didn't
have criminal in towns but they might
kill again
you have to lock them up a reason of
insanity which has the same kinds of
purposes as in fact lacking I'm up for
the because they have volition and
finally of course there's negligence
which has another set of potential so if
you say well they didn't mean it but
they did something bad because they were
stupid there's civil law that deals with
that so I want to kind of remove all
these legal questions which frankly I've
heard a lot of dirty money approaches to
that's my view on the legal side
you